factorizar el polinomio de abajo por su
máximo como un factor mono miel muy bien
hay que preguntarnos qué significa esto
que nos están pidiendo bueno tenemos
estos dos términos verdad y quiero
encontrar quién es un máximo común
factor mono mial y luego expresar esta
suma con dicho mono mío factor izado así
que cómo abordamos este problema una
forma de abordarlo es primero tomar
nuestros números que tenemos aquí en
este caso son 8 y 12 así que el primer
objetivo será encontrar el máximo común
divisor de 8 y 12 muy bien entonces
podríamos ver fácilmente que ambos son
divisibles entre 2 cierto también ambos
son divisibles entre 4 y ya no podemos
dividirlo entre algo más grande así que
el más grande de todos sus divisores
será en este caso 4 muy bien así que la
expresión o el mono mío que vamos a
factorizar al menos tiene a 4 como
número ahora nos preguntamos cómo
encontramos el máximo común
de x cuadrada y x verdad el siguiente
paso es fijarnos en lo que tiene la
variable x y tratar factorizar el máximo
común digamos factor mono mial de x
cuadrada y x entonces podemos ver que
claramente x divide tanto x cuadrada
como x y como éste ya no tiene un
exponente más grande en realidad ya no
podemos dividir entre algo más grande
que x verdad o quizás debería decir
entre una potencia más grande que la de
x que en este caso sería un cierto
entonces aquí tendremos que poner x muy
bien y hacemos exactamente el mismo caso
con la variable de verdad nos fijamos en
y pensamos que se divide tanto allí como
allí cuadrada cierto y ya no podemos
tomar una potencia más grande porque ya
ya no tiene una más grande en efecto
verdad entonces tendremos que colocar
aquí ya muy bien entonces justamente
esta expresión 4x es nuestro máximo
común
el factor mono mí al cierto ahora el
siguiente paso es ver cada uno de estos
términos como 4x jay x otra cosa verdad
entonces digamos empecemos con con este
que tenemos aquí entonces vamos a
expresar 8x cuadrada por jeff como 4x y
por otro otra expresión muy bien
entonces tendremos 4x que multiplica
alguna expresión y si nos preguntamos
cuál tendría que ser esta expresión
tendríamos que multiplicar a 4 por un
número para que nos dé 8 cierto entonces
ese número tiene que ser 2
ahora tenemos que multiplicar a x por
otra cosa para que nos dé x cuadrada eso
es muy fácil simplemente es equis y
tenemos que multiplicar ahí por otra
cosa para que nos dé que en este caso
pues tiene que ser 1 y no lo escribimos
verdad entonces aquí escribimos 8 x
cuadrada y como 4x x 2x
ahora vamos a sumar digamos la forma en
que podemos representar a 12 x y
cuadrada como 4x y por otra cosa verdad
entonces tendremos 4x por otra cosa nos
debe dar 12 x de cuadrada muy bien ahora
cual tendría que ser lo que tenemos que
colocar en este paréntesis que no hemos
rellenado bueno tenemos que ver que
cuatro por un número nos dé 12 ese
número es 3
ahora x por qué cosa nos da x bueno eso
sería 1 pero no no es necesario poner 3
por 1 verdad así que lo dejamos así y
luego multiplicamos allí por otra cosa
para que nos dé que cuadrada en este
caso tiene que ser y muy bien entonces
aquí ya tenemos expresado esta suma como
esta otra son la verdad nada más que
tenemos a 4 x factor' izado en cada uno
de los términos verdad es decir tenemos
actualizado el máximo común factor
nominal ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
factorizar 4
es decir podemos pensar que este 4x de
verdad lo estamos como des distribuyendo
es decir estamos haciendo el proceso
inverso a la propiedad distributiva
verdad entonces esto simplemente nos
quedará como vamos a ponerlo así con
este color 4x porque que multiplica que
multiplica a una expresión verdad en
este caso tendremos que colocar en el
primer sumando a 2x que es lo que
tenemos de este lado más otro sumando
que es lo que tenemos del lado derecho
que es 3 y muy bien y en realidad
podríamos verificarlo verdad 4x y por 2x
nos da 4 por 2 son 8 x x x x cuadrada y
por bueno simplemente se queda la de
verdad entonces tendríamos 8 x cuadrada
ya que es el primer término que tenemos
arriba y luego tenemos 4x jay que
multiplica a 3 es decir 4 por 3 son 12
la x se queda igual y que por qué nos
queda
cuadrada es decir tenemos este término
que se encuentra acá arriba entonces
esta es ya nuestra solución verdad
tendremos simplemente 4x que multiplica
a 2 x + 3g y hemos terminado